Erick's with us in philadelphia
pennsylvania hi Eric welcome to the Dave
Ramsey show hi Michael how are you today
better than I deserve what's up okay for
myself I'm wondering how I can help my
family out so the situation is that my
mom and uncle each owned a home there
two adjacent homes three bedroom homes
only one person lives in each of them
however the one that my uncle is in is
about to go into foreclosure
he took out a mortgage on my home just
to pay for his expenses the homes were
inherited from their parents and they've
used the money for the mortgage to
partially pay it back on itself and then
also they've used it for frivolous
expenses you know cars that they don't
need and so the mortgage is now in
foreclosure and what my mom who owns her
home and that turn comes from SSI and
disability which she wants to do is she
will ask me to purchase my uncle's home
and refinance the mortgage and she
thinks she can pay off the home with
some of the income of my uncle all signs
I think that's realistic and I told her
that I cannot do that so with that in
mind what she's moving towards doing is
taking out a home equity line of credit
on the home that she owned so she can
pay off the mortgage for him
and I don't know how to dissuade her not
to do that and I think if she does do
that
she will ultimately go into just a
spiral of debt and I'll end up having to
support them both so I don't really know
it does tell them what to try and do to
fix their situation so I'll just quote
them when they're all then potentially
without homes at all well you don't have
to support them both there's no law that
says that if your mother's doing cocaine
you don't give her cocaine you don't
give her money you know you don't
support people's misbehavior
that's called codependency and so no
your mother is about to make a huge
mistake and it's time somebody quit
bailing your uncle out he needs to just
sell that he needs just sell that house
is what you
and move and go rent something before it
gets foreclosed on but your love your
mother is you know I would just be all
up in her grill saying mom you just are
not gonna do this you are not gonna do
this
and if you do this don't you dare call
me after I've told you to do this if you
don't you dare call me and ask me for
money ever because I'm telling you right
now this guy's misbehaving with money
and he's going to take everybody in the
family down the drain with him you're
gonna have to get real strong about this
because nobody in your family talks
about the fact that your uncle is being
stupid regularly no one says it out loud
it's the dirty little secret it's a wink
and a nod it's the elephant in the room
that nobody discusses is standing on the
middle of your coffee table am I wrong
yeah so you need to have a very very
very clear conversation with your mother
how old are you I'm 24 years old
I'm on baby steps 3b I'm sitting upside
down payment on home yeah she's not
gonna listen to you do you have right
you know does she have a that not
exactly you got powder but syndrome'
big-time once somebody's powdered your
but they don't want your opinion about
money or sex um let's see
does she act does she go to church she
doesn't she's
yes how's her relationship with her
pastor it's a very large church that's
got about 5,000 members so there isn't
much relationship at her church but she
doesn't time every weekend who does she
respect that you can drag into this that
would get in her face and tell her not
to do this oh boy she - my father
occasionally but my relationship isn't
that great I don't I don't know someone
who women your father did you say yeah
they divorced
you know live together you know instead
of problems
yeah okay so here's the thing your
grandpa that left these two people
houses is he's just rolling this grave
right now this is killing now yeah this
is killing now this is not how that man
lived his life yeah all right the answer
is you need to if you can find someone
to speak into her life that she'll
listen to that you can bring into this
conversation and go sit down at her
kitchen table with this person who will
look at her and speak plainly to her and
she will hear them because she does not
need to do this no she doesn't think
that I can maybe get like assistance of
a professional like a lawyer or a
counselor or someone well I only if she
would listen is there a family attorney
that did this will that cause the two
people to end up with these houses that
she'd listened to your grandpa's
attorney eventually yeah you know as a
small town your grandpa's attorneys is
well respected and he would sit down
with her and go you know John or
whatever your grandpa's name was he'd be
having a fit right now Martha don't do
this right and if you got somebody that
can do that that's what I'm looking for
him and look pray and ask God to send
that person into your mind or into her
life because I'm afraid that she's not
gonna it's not because I don't think
you're smart at 24 you're asking all the
right questions you've really got a
pretty good handle on this but I want to
relieve you of responsibility to meant
to take care of people who refuse to do
smart things just because they're in
their family that is not a moral
responsibility on your part so um you
think is the best course of option for
him to sell the house and right now yes
he has lost the house he lost the house
by his misbehavior it's in foreclosure
he needs to sell it before he loses it
right yeah he does not have a way to
save this house without someone else
putting all their assets at risk to bail
him out and then he's not gonna change
anything and then the next time it goes
around they're all gonna lose their
houses
that's what's gonna happen does it this
guy hadn't changed a thing and yeah he
needs to sell his house that's what he
needs to do and go rent something and I
screwed up and lost the house
that's what amounts to and start again
fresh and he can start fresh and your
mom won't be okay and let her stay in
her paid for house while she's on that's
si which is exactly what she needs she
does not need a mortgage I'm sorry man
I'm frustrated with you